ciao ragazzi della challenge epica
matrimonio allora abbiamo già fatto la
challenge tre colori di quella la sua
legge 5 colori di glik la challenge tre
colori di click no pigmenti trick per
esseri viventi perché ho pensato ma
perché non le facciamo tutte assieme ma
cammarata
ecco qua la ruota allora la runa
desidera quale dovremo pescare ma non
solo pescare dovremmo magari a
sceglierlo noi o pesca l'open data dovrà
solo con l'altro
ci sono tante e mezzo grazie per il
consiglio sta facendo e l'altro
rifugiati al colore però se tu fai
troppo da cattivo se di qualcosa di
schifoso per il mit live c'è anche lo
scambio potrebbe ricapitare che a te
quindi d'evitare petta alghero quindi
perfezione stessa che ne succederanno
delle belle perché c'è anche lo scalcia
di più dello zoom e curiosi di vedere di
che colore diventeranno i nostri timer
come limiteranno con tutti questi colori
marra
utilizzarlo anche se non sono molto
giallo e io mi grosso io volevo essere
più in rosso ma anche vita fibroso
quindi alla fine ho detto vabbè telepass
utilizzarlo lei che se volete vedere
altri challenge slime con la ruote
consensi sicure quali altri challenge
volete vedere vinicola che il mio libro
è ancora scontato solo se non lo trovate
anche tutte le premure regalo perfetto
per la befana caricando di giorno alla
fine questo video vi lascio lo schermo
su cui potete cliccare per andare a
vedere anche i beer digitale sotterrando
i pokémon o de the sims figli abbiamo
anche fatto il patrimonio quindi poi li
mandate a vederlo e allora siete pronti
per del prof
stamattina i giovani e la carta pormi se
usato ha convinto io dai piano
[Musica]
preoccupati che noi ci scambiamo la
gioco tra l'altro io sto acquistando la
colla e la sua parte c'era un corto nero
quindi non posso a te ma perché in
questo caso avviene di dettaglio allora
ci si giri tutto se deve scegliere tra
colorati di tre pigmenti il numero uno e
colore l'uno due di per il libro tre big
man il segno un numero tra 1 e 3
la risposta quindi assetto glitter ok i
glitter sono 24
il campo conoscendo il 6 e moore tra 124
12 secondo i miei castri 55
quindi partendo dalla panda destra verso
sinistra 45
viola massimo poi io scelgo i pit rossi
come mai non mi dire che vuoi fare
nuovamente lo slide di natale questi
sono più vuoi fare in un momento creata
da allora ogni due ingredienti andremo a
metterli rischiano che faranno vedere da
vicino come esse quindi prima prendiamo
un altro cliente poi andiamo a mischia
ne pensavo stesse non scendere poi
allora perché ci dovevamo cambiare
colori di te quindi questo segna il
pigmento brain data e dove sono qua sì
questa loro che già ora i viola allora
questa combinato i colori
[Musica]
quindi prima di lieviti del muro da 3 a
36 il numero da 1 a 3 ei 6 anni un
numero la volata a scomputo essere che
la mia city non si capisce il termine ma
belli io chiedo io per te allora si
sceglie l'uno da 1 a 3 lo stesso nome
quelle due sono glitter 2 glitterati
jalil un'altra 122 secondo i meccanici
che vuoi fare lo slide di natale qui
vita ai colori di natale
allora iniziamo con il mister viola che
bello
cappelletti trento prestato una cosa del
colore del mio team
i pigmenti allora prima da mischiare
quest'inter di orde che è più
trasparenti di quella cleopatra perché
quello che cleopatra rimaneva un po
giallina anche se il profumo era buono
sappiamo di mandorlo però rimaneva
troppo giallina questo mese in più
trasparente quindi vediamo un po come
diventa poi manomettere i pigmenti
dorati che bella famiglia dire adesso
che sa il viola ed ora ti piace o non lo
so dipende da cosa mi esce dopo pronti a
vedere la magia che belli però solo che
non mi capiti qualche colorate sfigato
così si studia che sia bellissimo e
colorando molto aspetto vediamo di
grigio now resto diventa misurato ma che
bello e thibodeau raggio con il glitter
di ora in ora e veli di mobilità o l'ora
il mio c'è solo questa cosetta nera lim
dio chiede che non sa che cos'è concio
prima con i primi che mi sono city cioè
i glitter rossi che ho scelto io di
analisi ma tra poco finito questo è lo
slide delle festività lo slime festivo
qualche bellissimo che lo vuoi cercare
di tenere bello chiaro
faccio un appello non pensa è lo provo a
fare un click live di natale vedremo
come carino è bello non perdona io no
tanto sotto l'aspetto proverà anche
secondo da sinistra a destra
fate le vendite letta secondo da destra
mette la nostra destra ma primo seconda
[Musica]
colorante bendata band ma io non volevo
che lasciato trasparente lei meschini
città se avrai la maledizione aspetta
[Applauso]
dove sono questi sono i segni sono tutti
questi quasi sicura ben chiare le foto
di natale e il blu del cielo di sotto
area blu del presente sotto l'alto il
blu del cielo il presidente sotto
l'albero di natale
certo se si va a destra 123456 o prof
un rosso scuro
si stanno bene dai sommato se questa
pacchetto gialla è capitato colorante
sceglie l'altro secco tanto bravo allora
sono molto intensi tale che l'ha
mostrata con intensità perché gli
insegnerei il verde però so che c'è il
pericolo dello scambio brava quindi devo
stare un po attenta questo rosa forte
diventato comprimari morrone allora mi è
capitato prima di l'ittero il colore
ogni colorate vediamo un po come questo
rosa mischiato con pigmento giallo per
dovere e grigia no
[Applauso]
si guarda sono colore marrone si ride
con mettiamo ora inter rossi ha finora
gestito meglio sembra un galaxy al
contrario come caspian contrario che non
è tipo con i colori invertiti non guarda
che si vero sì tanta tanta
perché dove riflessi verdi no io non li
vedo tutto ripeto l'ingresso che non lo
sento il bergamo
no non ti ringrazio sì esatto non l'hai
tu mi è caduta sulla paletta nò
sarà un casino lo sono ancora nelle
menti prima mischiarlo prima per il
grandissimo è un po su e scurissimo
adesso questi ti capitano altri
coloranti
sarà un bel miscuglio una bella zuppetta
amore bello devo dire il colore
bellissimo scolarità l sembra un cielo
stellato di obiettive vediamo controllo
[Musica]
vediamo di 120 correzione tra l'altro
sempre stato il mio slime sono un po i
prodotti come la mia maglia
l'altra tra stata rincarata che sia
stata come la base rosa corte di appello
promesso rosso mattino molto tipo bronzo
scelgo questo tipo rosa e rosso ora è un
rosa rosso l'aver nota ma ditemi voi
secondo poi che colore è questo scrivete
nei commenti
e fortuna che implicasse gli allora
scendere ed è mia vita è pregato di
attenderti alla cassa con il glitter
cassetto di jolo signora
gambe papavero sia colorando i segni e
l'altro metà delle scelte facili di rame
è bellissima hai fatto la zuppa di
carota
[Musica]
[Applauso]
più di mezza scelgo questa estate è
stato il bellissimo prendo questo è qual
è questo questo qua che bello guerra di
tifo non violento
c'è un bellissimo a un altro fattore di
sono molto simili quindi vicino anche
così fantastico ringrazio arrivata
allora mettiamo primo i glitter pronto
non rota dimmi come da me veniero
montanaro e che adesso sono rosa ma devo
sempre quindi ai vostri clienti un bel
color pronto ha detto riuscire a rosa
guarda non pensa proprio a grosso terra
vediamo il colore
e bellissimo e un bel colore rosa mazza
nel vero e bronzo che è pronto e sul
rosso oh che bello
e bellissimo il colore adesso spero che
non sono sfigati che mi capita questo il
colore il brutto perché adesso colore è
venuto qui per morte dopo le parti si
può più fare la rete era ancora come te
per la combinazione proprio marte
rischiavano di euro consumi molto
ridotti i fondi una rara facendo
politica le braccia il proprio morte di
colui che non ebbe 40 di tutti allora io
vado prima con il marrone ma marrone vai
che uscirà un galaxy spera fantastico
del marrone marrone giriamo guarda verso
tantissimo di colorante non ci vede più
niente tutto blu così sarebbe del verde
ti mettono veramente marrone beh vediamo
mischiato col viola sezione di san
marone viola come di mezzo secondo terra
bellissimo
guarda guarda non si vede più assorbito
tutto il blu scuro però è rimasto uguale
tanto parte come temi niente perché
troppo bravo penso che uscisse meglio se
solo schiarito un pochettino dei titoli
in giro piano guarda io provo a rigirare
sono girate troppo sera ci fate
incorpora tanto siamo messi dentro
queste ci mettiamo che sito voglio il
fango brutto tumore solamente dire la
verità con le più bello guardate
guardate che colore meraviglioso i miei
super metallizzati sul web un mustang
metallizzato contro blu violetto bravo
il colore del mio primo no chiaro questo
32 10
fatevi bene il mio color martin bronzo
metano svelato scambiamo con lo sto
fango
spero allora indietro perché bellissima
ti capita il campo impossibile bene
perché non è molto comodo e del suo team
tra l'altro
[Musica]
fortuna che le grandi ti sto fango
miu miu miu miu miu miu è rischioso si è
arreso grammatura brevetti no dobbiamo
per forza scambiarmi noi uno stadio
pieno
[Musica]
[Risate]
e fortunato qua il segno del giglio a
cedere un pigmento per farlo un pochino
meglio scelto il pigmento bianco così lo
al tema un po costo fund romanian così
così almeno lo temo non so come
diventerà lo so io lo so io no questo è
loro idea e ha detto sei d'argento pure
gente ecco bianco perlato ho parlato ha
chiuso gambe allora secondo me la ruota
si è arrabbiato che la ditta numerose
ora si fa qualche dispetto cioè sullo
scotch di scambio con questo lavoro sarà
terminato la cambia cambia cambia poco o
niente scambi propria libertà conta
molto valore del bene che mi piace così
non me lo rovinare tanto al mio nuovo
loro tornano addormenta bene mi piace
tra il mio slogan è un bellissimo
celeste così non me lo voglio
sono migliaia meno male che hai preso
quello almeno lei almeno il più o meno
sullo stesso colore
[Musica]
la destra 46 rosso di nuovo anche dura
1234567 è infatti gli stessi colori però
migliorerà proprio allora vediamo di
migliorare questo colore orribile questo
monocolore viola bellissimo rapporto
sarete persona che questi corsi sono
usciti non lo vanno a distruggerlo ma
che distruggerebbe mai migliorare
bellissimo el'asta migliora sembra un
potrete pro questo segmento
ecco stella risucchiato e non è cambiato
niente così pari a mettere così tanto
blu
se metti conficcato colorate poi non si
vede niente noti ha risucchiato anche
quello un po che film si vedono vedi è
colma
certo abbiamo nel mio bellissimo live
parte come diventa abbiamo vediamo
innanzitutto di schiarire questo fango
me che c'è qui ma che va in curva è
bellissimo questa fanghiglia ottiene
immesso tantissimo era male almeno si
schiarisce un proxy io come dimenticato
adesso proviamo però potrebbe diventare
metallizzato e parla cioè il tuo non
appare niente tutti questi riflette non
si è sorbito nulla quello forse un
pochino sito si è bellissimo bari un
motore normale tanto l'ho sistemato
questo sma che dava tanta bellezza
questo slime orribile
[Musica]
che nell'ennesimo privati agli ultimi
due turni quindi giro la roccia volta io
e quindi vediamo cosa scatta sia moscato
ultimo ingrediente cambio stadio
scarichiamo la versione audio audio
[Musica]
no questo no pigmento stesso momento
filmetto quattro da destra
[Musica]
quindi fini di ricerca di 323 quindi per
i twitter sono 24 i segni numero a caso
tra 124 madre è un segreto dietro
monoposto ma allinea alle altre non so
che voi vi divertite tutta parete per
fare anche noi cercate un sacco basta
come potrete vedere comunque se andiamo
a vedere sportiva ingrediente vediamo
come vedete lo slime finale ecco qua
mettiamo questo collo perché non c'entra
niente in questo blog
ma come mai provato a metter a roma era
non migliorabile
vediamo il puc in questo rosa hai messo
veramente troppo e accaduto che devo
fare è non è il terzetto con quelle di
placcare
se non si è almeno lo sta schiarendo un
pochino fatto voteranno per vitale
perché vitale lo ha fatto più bello ma
qual è questa
domani è il primo e unico e va bene così
male voto italiano mi raccomando non me
lo attivare troppo lo slime minor ma
senti chi parla
quello che vedete anche di carbonara
guardatelo migliorato questa cosa qui
non si vede tanto dopo però attivo te lo
riprende dai quell'altro mio figlio va
bene parla ora andiamo da sparo non
vorremmo mai vedere come saranno attivi
come sarà il colore riflessi e poi
potrebbe notare subito lì non si è visto
giocare il mio sliding appello
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ed ecco il mio slime barra ex slime di
vitale alla fine è uscito un monocolore
come sospettavo non è proprio blu e non
senta di viola scuro proprio perché
c'era il rosa quindi in due rosa ed è
diventato una sorta di viola largo
stesse fighissima booking ottimo poi
supera l'ostico e si vedono un pochino i
glitter è un po per lato poco poco
metallizzato non tantissimo perché
appunto il kamarat e broken eletta tappa
la coperto questo è il colore quindi un
mix di colori e pigmenti un po per lato
biancoblù moviola veri gala era o no
questo è perché ho fatto io
sì perché ostica bellissimo allora poi
dopo
poi dopo che diete vicky dovete votare
guardate incoraggiato la presentazione
allora non sono proprio soddisfatto del
colore blu sono riuscito a farlo
diventare poco poco più chiaro rispetto
a quella rispetto a quel famiglia che
pure in realtà rispetto al fango che
aveva fatto anche poking bruegel più
conosciuto quello di berlino non è
uscito molto intenso colore in questo
pensavo sarebbe il sito
ecco il colore allora votate votate
votate
gente vi sia vita per vizio vitale se
volete che vi facciamo questa challenge
riparla magari lasciamo qua questo caso
linee su cui cliccare se volete vedere
il canale di evitare se volete vedere
l'inter challenge video divertenti
plicanti su quella che professorezza